what we just witnessed I don't see  Republicans winning ever again I I  talked about this specifically in my  earlier video today now you could  criticize Donald Trump since his main  issue for this midterm was talking about  the 2020 election you could criticize  them from doing fundraisers for Masters  and and receiving 99 out of a hundred  dollars and giving only one dollar to  Masters that was uh uh you know that was  that was outpaid for by his opponent 80  million dollars to 12 million dollars  you could criticize them on that but  when you have the ballot harvesting when  you have the mail-in ballots  additionally when you have big Tech  censorship when you have yellow bellies  and neoconservatives in the Republican  party I don't see them winning ever  again in the near future what else could  help them win they have no institutional  power to change any of this they won't  change anything and even if they did I  wouldn't even have any uh you know  optimism that they would